[Music]
good morning my name is rocky Taylor
I've been a stunt man for 54 years I've
started around 1961 yes I'm the hottest
working stunt man I suppose I was the
youngest
now I'm the oldest
[Music]
the source fell into it I could fall
about and do what the actors couldn't do
ie get punched for over a chair dives
and rolled along the ground my first
stunt job was a film called The Young
Ones with Sir Cliff Richard they gave me
a Guinness record I've got it over there
the oldest still working stuntmen in
England the only stuntman to double for
two bombs in one year Roger Moore the
name is Bart in Sean Connery my last
film was this Sunday I was working on a
little car chase sequence around - Fargo
square which was great
I mean I've been in it for so many years
now and I can't think of anything else I
can do
[Music]
I had a very bad accident on deaf way
through I need to go guilt this is the
this shot of me doing the fall which
nearly took my life when they blew it
out before I got to the edge I'll run
through the flames put my hands up over
my eyes came through broke my back
pelvis
thank God I survived I don't know how I
survived but you're gonna get a little
knock and a little bruise that's part of
the job
why do I keep doing it I've had a great
life I've been around the world twice
I've met all the stars
I love it there's nothing else about it
you
[Music]